on accueille nathalie arthaud bonjour
nathalie arthaud bonjour merci beaucoup
ben est notre invité ce matin vous êtes
candidate à la présidentielle candidate
pour lutte ouvrière et on est ton semble
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représentée par stéphane bern et de
ouest france bonjour stéphane bonjour
bonjour bonjour où commence évidemment
par une question sur l'ukraine 1
nathalie arthaud 13e jour de guerre en
ukraine si vous étiez président de la
république est ce que vous feriez vous
est-ce qu'on vous agiriez comme emmanuel
macron comme lui non ça c'est sûr non
non non moi je m'appuierai sur
l'aspiration à la paix à ce que les
armes se taisent qui existe qui existe
qui existe dans la population
ukrainienne déjà puisqu'on voit un
certain nombre de manifestants en
ukraine d'ailleurs qui sont
systématiquement arrêtés persécutés etc
mais qui n'en veulent pas de cette
guerre et puis sur l'aspiration à faire
taire les armes qui existe aussi en
ukraine voilà parce que moi je pense de
fait un certain temps arrêté oui mais
les leaders étant lilia il ya aussi en
ukraine des femmes et d'hommes qui
veulent que les armes se taisent il y en
a aussi en ukraine et donc moi je veux
ma purée là dessus pour pour qu'on fasse
tout pour qu'il y ait pas un bain de
sang voilà vous êtes prononcées contre
les sanctions économiques en disant à la
france pour les populations qui
trinquent et mais vous êtes aussi
prononcé contre la livraison d'armes à
l'ukraine est ce que ce sont des
positions que vous maintenez moi je dois
avouer que je suis révolté révolté de
voir que finalement
c'est le camp occidental impérialistes
qui a contribué grandement à plonger
l'ukraine dans cet enfer là parce que
les responsabilités sont partagées a
bien sûr qu'elles sont partagés bien sûr
très
clairement c'est poutine qui a fait le
pas décisif vers cette guerre fratricide
mai l'engrenage il a été mis en place
par cette rivalité à la fois un camp
impérialiste avec les états unis et
l'otan qui a poussé à pour s'étendre
jusque jusqu'aux frontières de la russie
en développant les bases militaires etc
etc et puis l'autre côté la bureaucratie
russe le maître du kremlin qui défend
effectivement l'intérêt de sa caste et
puis d'un certain nombre d'oligarques
russes
que c'est ce bras de fer là mais moi ce
qui me révolte c'est ça c'est que
finalement
ils ont cette rivalité et le camp
occidental et impérialiste et y compris
notre propre gouvernement a à jouer avec
la peau des ukrainiens et ce sont eux
qui ont plongé les ukrainiens dans cette
dent dans cet enfer dans cet enfer des
bombes alors aujourd'hui qu'il se pose
en sauveur moi je dois vous dire que ça
me révolte ça me révolte littéralement
donc voila moi je comprends très bien 1
ceux qui aujourd'hui en ukraine cherche
à se défendre et à se protéger mais
clairement
croire que ceux là on les aide pas on
est pas la résistance mais qui ont qui
ont moi je m'avance mais non européenne
mais ceux qui ont été les responsables
ceux qui ont été les fauteurs de guerre
on s'en remet encore à eux moi je pense
que voilà alors comment vous les
aimeriez vous faire rêver là c'est bien
faire passer le camp occidental
impérialistes pour la blanche colombe
qui va venir sauver les peuples alors
même qu'ils ont été au coeur même du
problème c'est ccc se tromper c'est ce
conte tromper cruellement est ce que
vous voulez dans les pubs comment vous
les aidez vos concrètes mal au rebond ce
matin vous l'êtes deriez le peuple non
mais moi je sais très bien qu'on me met
toujours au pied du mur alors pendant
des décennies et des décennies des
décennies ceux qui dirigent ce monde
nous aurons nous nous nous plonge donc
dans des situations catastrophiques et
on demande à madame arthaud d'arrivée et
d'avoir la solution moi la solution ce
que je pensais qu'elle viendra lille bat
à la présidentielle on vous demande
qu'est ce que vous feriez si oui il est
allé mais je tiens quand même à
souligner la responsabilité écrasante de
nos dirigeants qui nous mène vers le
vert vers la guerre qui qui qui est
responsable de cette misère du monde qui
dit moi alors moi moi ma conviction
profonde c'est que la solution elle
viendra des peuples même de sopko
justement qu'on essaye de de fer
s'entretuer en ce moment ça viendra de
leurs réactions en bref cap un peu
d'utopie quand vous allez là d'état
allait devenir poutine est ce que c'est
pas un peu utopique de dire mais la
solution viendra dans l'utopie l'utopie
c'est de croire que ce sont les
dirigeants en place les dirigeants les
maîtres du monde et je parle bien sûr de
la première puissance impériale ce qui
va résoudre le problème ils mettent le
monde en coupe réglée et ce n'est pas
que l'ukraine c'est le monde entier sait
ce qui se passe au moyen orient parce
que des guerres y en a aussi au
moyen-orient c'est ce qui se passe en
afrique la france sauveuse de l'afrique
ça fait combien mais depuis toujours on
nous raconte ce conte de fées même quand
elle était aller coloniser l'afrique
c'était la sauveuse de l'afrique allez
on va parler des conséquences les
conséquences domestiques de cette guerre
les prix augmentent prix de l'essence
prix des matières premières comment est
ce que vous pourriez qu'est ce que vous
pourriez proposé pour aider les français
à faire face ou alors est même sûr sur
les sanctions je tiens quand même à dire
que les premiers qui en souffriront ça
sera les travailleuses et les
travailleurs russes les retraités russe
tous ceux qui sont déjà dans la misère
qu'ils en souffriront mais énormément je
tiens quand même à le dire parce que
parce que la voilà on en oublie toujours
finalement les souffrances qu'on inflige
au peuple mais je tiens aussi à dire
qu'on tue avec des bombes c'est vrai
mais on tue aussi en fomentant la misère
ça on tue aussi comme ça donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis content ces
sanctions est par ailleurs ben oui oui
ça aura des lots domestiques ça on a
déjà aujourd'hui mais voyez déjà
aujourd'hui moi ce qui me marque c'est
que rien que de dire il y aura des
sanctions alors même qu'elles n'ont pas
été effective le prix du baril de
pétrole flambe le prix ça veut dire quoi
se dire qu'il ya de la spéculation
ça veut dire qu'il ya des profiteurs de
cette guerre aujourd'hui les total
l'écart guile les louis dreyfus les
grands armateurs ils en profitent déjà
mais c'est quand même dingue mais en moi
que vous faites pour aider les
francs-maçons mention seigneur emmanuel
macron promise va l'être sur l'essence
et une bonne nouvelle ça pourrait bien
ma solution c'est d'aller prendre sur
les profits sur les profits
exceptionnels de toute cette spéculation
de tous de tous ces profiteurs de guerre
on va aller prendre on va on va les
taxes et oui et puis comme ça peut-être
qu'on arrivera à diminuer un petit peu
les taxes et allait supprimer même les
taxes que nous payons mais moi je crois
aussi que le problème essentiel vous
savez ce sont les bas salaires ce sont
les petites pensions de retraite c'était
déjà des problèmes avant qu'ils aient
cette flambée des prix c'était déjà des
problèmes puisque c'était à partir de là
qu'ils avaient eue
bâle l'irruption de ce mouvement d gilet
jaune donc c'était déjà un problème mais
là là effectivement c'est de l'argent
programme vous vous proposez de
d'exonérer les travailleurs de taxes sur
les carburants longue les travailleurs
c'est comment comment est-ce que comment
est ce que vous faites le distinguo en
face de façon générale moi je suis
contre que les femmes et les hommes des
classes populaires du monde du travail
psd paye des taxes et je suis pour ses
fameuses taxes indirectes qui pèse qui
pèse mais je suis pour que c'est axa
soit payée justement par par les profits
ses profits qu'on voit s'accumuler mais
moi le coeur de mon programme c'est de
dire il faut l'augmentation générale des
salaires des allocations et des pensions
et que ces salaires soient indexés soit
indexée sur l'inflation c'est-à-dire
qu'ils augmentent automatiquement avec
l'inflation mesurée mais je dirais même
mois mois après mois qu'on attende pas
un an c'est à dire d'avoir perdu 2,7
appauvri et puis donc il faut l'indexage
dans un programme il ya une augmentation
de salaires de 300 euros il ya le smic à
300 400 ou 500 euros même là le smic est
porté à 2000 euros les pensions de
retraite qui ne peuvent pas être
inférieur à 2000 euros c'est ce que vous
dites comment vous financer tout ça mais
je fis danse tout ça comme on finance
aujourd'hui les dividendes de certains
comment fait-on pour pour pour que
quelques le plus riche de france et
bernard arnauld bernard arnault et ils
encaissent 2 smic par minute de smic par
minute vous entendez ça et c'est vrai
mais d'un certain nombre de grandes
familles bourgeoises qui n'ont jamais
été aussi riches et qu'ils font les
riche les riches entrepreneurs qui finit
il faut se rendra sur ses profits dans
sur ces fortunes sifflé à combien tous
et vous savez ça sera pas suffisant et
bien rien que les 137 milliards qui ont
été annoncées pour les 40 premières
entreprises en france ça fait trois ou
quatre millions d'emplois
vous vous rendez compte rien qu'en
prenant sur les les et dividendes est 40
plus grandes entreprises ont créé trois
et quatre millions d'emplois payer 2000
euros cotisations comprises dans vous
vous rendez compte l'argent tient dans
la société 6 il ya de l'argent et si
vous mettiez en a pas bah moi là l'autre
mesure que je défends c'est l'abolition
du secret des affaires c'est à dire la
possibilité pour les travailleurs
d'aller voir l'argent qu'il y a dans ces
grands groupes dans ces grands groupes
parce qu'il ya de l'argent il faut qu'on
lève le voile sur les circuits de
l'argent alors dans les autres mesures
que qu'il va falloir financer aussi cia
l'abaissement du temps de travail sans
baisse de salaire vous parler de la
retraite à 60 ans aussi dans votre
programme
ça ça fait partie des choses que vous
pouvez faire passer avec ce que vous
venez de décrire ces on prend l'argent
là du côté des profits tous assurent
tout ça est suffisant pour financer
l'ensemble de vos programmes mais bien
sûr que c'est suffisant bon avec cette
possibilité ou possibilité d'aller voir
l'argent on le mesure reste très
concrètement mais juste je vois là une
1h une question pourquoi ce qui était
possible il y a trente ans en terme de
retraite de droits à la retraite ne le
seraient plus aujourd'hui pourquoi la
société s'est elle appauvrit est on
capable et ont moins capables de
produire est ce que est ce qu'on a vu
une chute vertigineuse de la
productivité y à il ya quand même d
industrialisation et quand même une
désindustrialisation massive du pays on
a un problème de déficit de la balance
commerciale enfin on voit bien que le la
capacité de production la france un cas
quand même globalement beaucoup baissé
et non sauf que ça ne apparemment ça
n'empêche pas une minorité de s'enrichir
comme jamais ça n'empêche pas les
profits d'exploser donc non tout le tout
le travail qu'ils réalisent et de toute
façon il vient des travailleurs eux
mêmes donc moi je pense que la priorité
elle doit être aux salaires aux emplois
et aux retraites et dernière question
est manuel un dire qu'il refusait
débattre avec les candidats ni c'est le
premier tour vous le regrettez ben oui
bien sûr je le regrette en fait de toute
façon c'est un cirque électoral tout ça
et je peux vous dire qu'il n'ya pas
d'égalité c'est comme dans la société il
ya ceux qui sont en hausse et qui sont
en bas il ya des grands candidats et les
petits candidats c'est vraiment le
reflet complet du mode de fonctionnement
de notre société tout entière merci
natalia retour merci beaucoup d'avoir
versé notre invité ce matin
[Musique]